(water splashing)
- [Jeff] It's unique, right?
We're not anywhere near the ocean.
And yet we're teaching inmates
how to commercial dive,
so that they can get
out and get a good job
and be productive members of society.
- [Man] One, two, three, four.
- [Jeff] It's a hard thing
to get your mind around.
At the end of the day we're
seeing guys change their lives.
- One, two, three, dive school.
- My name's Jeff Powers.
I'm the lead dive instructor
at the California Institution for Men.
The Marine Technology Training Center
is a commercial dive program run
by CALPIA within the prison.
The dive school was founded in 1970.
Hundreds of guys have graduated
from the program since then.
And the lion's share of our
graduates are successes.
Only 6% of our guys come back to prison.
We have guys offshore
in the oil platforms.
We have guys working on ships
in every port in the country.
Our graduates get out there and kick butt.
It's that simple, and they love it.
(water splashing)
The program is 18 months.
Physical training is a huge
part of this dive school.
Because they're here at seven
in the morning ready to go.
Then, they start into their
physical training routine.
That usually involves lots of running,
lots of calisthenics, lots of swimming.
Everything is more of a
challenge under water.
Projects have to be taken super seriously.
They can be considered
life or death obviously.
One of the biggest skills
that a dive student's
gotta learn is just
working on a dive station.
It's founded on safety and teamwork.
Naturally, we want our guys to be strong.
But we also want our guys to be smart.
Do we have a pretty good
grasp on Dalton's Law?
We spend as much time in the classroom
as we do doing hands on stuff.
It's very important
that my guys understand
diving physics, diving
physiology in-depth.
We approach the learning as a team.
And we don't let guys fall off.
- Up and over.
I've been imprisoned for about 11 years,
and I have about 18 months left.
My driving force for being here is
I want to be more than just F84205.
That's my inmate number.
I want to be more than that.
I want to prove to everybody
else that I'm more than that.
I'm a person; I made a mistake.
But at least I can say
that I gave it my all here.
And I can step out of here
and give myself a chance.
- I was in prison for
12 years, nine months.
I did eight of those years
at California Institution for Men.
And I've been out of prison
for six and a half years.
I didn't have any chances left.
You know.
One more mistake and this
would've been my life forever.
I feel every day that
the life that I have now,
I owe to this program.
In some little way everything
I do as far as my skills,
even skills I've learned
since I've left here.
It's all based on what I
learned from this program.
- [Man] Diver resurface.
- [Man] That's a diver resurface.
- If a guy isn't given
some sort of work skill,
some sort of life skills,
then how is he not gonna go back
to what he was doing before?
We give them a different chance.
It's not for sure.
But it gives them a good step
up with those life skills
to do something right.
The skills we teach them
here are gonna make them
good employees wherever they end up.
That's pretty fulfilling.
You know that these guys can actually
do something out of the training
that I've been part of so that's special.
(orchestral music)